deux garçons deux filles dont ça peut en
cuir hein il y a des soirées qu'on
commençait beaucoup plus mal dit rien
et maintenant voici mon stagiaire Tom
villa
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi le générique là c'est le
générique du petit journalier moi je
pose ma candidature moi aussi j'ai envie
de reprendre le petit journal ça va j'ai
un programme j'ai une vision voilà tu
vas pas passer de stagiaire à
présentateur du Petit Journal mais
pourquoi pas il y a bien des présidents
de Corrèze qui sont devenus le président
de la République hein on a vu on a vu le
résultat
très beau plateau ce soir Thierry très
varié Vincent Lagaffe Vincent je l'adore
c'est l'idole de ma jeunesse tous les
soirs j'étais devant l'or à l'appel Le
Bigdil sur TF1 et j'avais toujours cette
même question où trouve-t-il toute cette
énergie et ses costumes ridicules
non mais vous avez été l'un des premiers
à voir des vos propres danseuses dans
vos émissions les gars faites vous
rappelez Thierry desgafettes j'adorais
les Gafettes ça valait les pâtissiers et
Talia enfin stalia et Titia qu'on
embrasse d'ailleurs comme comme toutes
les autres serveuses du Buffalo Grill de
Neuilly-sur-Marne
[Applaudissements]
et puis la gaffe les plus jeunes ne le
savent pas mais c'est un homme de télé
mais c'est aussi un homme de scène il a
démarré par ça et aujourd'hui vous
interdisez d'ailleurs de refaire du one
man show alors je savais pas qu'on
pouvait faire ça chérie qu'on pouvait se
faire interdire de casino mais de serre
je savais pas non mais c'est vrai faut
absolument mettre au courant quand même
cohérent Thierry
alors vous venez aujourd'hui Vincent
parce que vous avez ouvert une école de
Flyboard d'overboard et de jetpack à
Cavalaire-sur-Mer c'est super alors le
Flyboard j'explique rapidement c'est
apprendre aux gens à voler sur l'eau
Jésus a marché sur l'eau vous vous volez
au-dessus de l'eau alors s'il y a des
mecs qui arrivent avec des poteaux et
des clous un conseil couré
Thierry breillard bonsoir
elle était facile mais c'est toujours
plaisir la gaffe et Bryar sur le même
plateau il y en a un des deux qui a pris
un pseudo et l'autre qui aurait dû en
prendre un et non en sont un mec de
gauche à ça ça fait plaisir Thierry
parce que on a eu que des mecs de droite
là c'est derrière semaine j'ai failli
passer pour un mec de gauche j'ai une
réputation à tenir quand même alors vous
êtes le secrétaire d'État chargé des
sports et c'est vrai que bosser au
ministère des Sports sous François
Hollande ça doit pas être évident à
assumer c'est comme bosser au ministère
de la Solidarité sous Sarkozy
c'est en tout cas vous faites partie des
des fidèles du président et vous avez
dit Hollande doit rassembler je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec vous Thierry
il doit rassembler et ses affaires est
parti très vite
[Applaudissements]
Natacha Polony bonsoir
il y a des soirées qu'on commence
beaucoup plus mal tirer alors moi je
propose un truc on éteint la lumière on
se met tout nu on voit ce qui se passe
non non non je rigole non non deuxième
passage de l'année dans Salut les
Terriens alors bon d'habitude ça partir
du troisième passage donc je vous fais
la petite carte de fidélité Salut les
Terriens voilà hop un coup de tampon et
au troisième il y a un quai Royal offert
donc voilà ça c'est le petit cadeau de
la
[Applaudissements]
voilà et
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson
n'a pas voulu vous poser Thierry
Braillard alors Thierry vous êtes sous
la tutelle de Patrick Kanner moi je mon
twitter c'est Thierry Ardisson du coup
vous aussi après le boulot vous avez
droit à une coupe de champagne un gros
pets
Marina Kaye Marina votre première
chanson parue en 2014 s'intitule
homeless ce qui signifie sans abri
est-ce que c'est un hommage à tous ceux
qui n'ont pas de toi ou c'est juste pour
François Hollande en 2017
et pour terminer Natacha Polony Natacha
sur Paris Première vous présentez
l'émission polonium vous avez choisi ce
type parce que imodium ça faisait trop
chier
allez tiens bonne émission et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu